todos somos fama este es el grito de
batalla de las fuerzas armadas malienses
en las calles centenares se volcaron a
apoyar la acción de la junta militar la
cual tomó el poder en mali en el año
2020 en las pancartas de los
manifestantes denuncian a la cedeao y
sus sanciones económicas la comunidad de
áfrica del oeste presiona a los
militares para que entreguen rápidamente
el poder a los civiles en varios lugares
banderas rusas como un desafío al
ejército francés involucrado en mali
desde mayo del 2013 que últimamente
acusó a los mercenarios del grupo wagner
de participar en abusos la milicia rusa
habría enterrado cuerpos cerca de una
base militar para incriminar a soldados
franceses desde hace una década amalia
está hundida en una profunda crisis de
seguridad con un aumento de los ataques
de cadistas para enfrentarse con la
situación la junta militar se acercó a
moscú y tomó distancia de parís después
de meses de tensiones diplomáticas las
autoridades francesas anunciaron en
febrero el retiro progresivo de sus
tropas